hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et tu table le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger programme il ya une
équipe de journalistes derrière qui
bossent comme des dingues dont un un
grand il ya un gros journée c'est pas le
moreira aussi tu étais derrière les
productions qui produit les et ça
s'adresse aviation s'est vraiment mais
c'est vraiment des grands journalistes
ils travaillent à l'américaine aux etats
unis ils ont ça 66 minutes ils ont des
programmes comme ça le bac signale fait
la télévision domaine de l'information
en tout cas c'était les tops et les
flops de cette semaine et nous allons
attaquer maintenant notre partie télé
réalité nous allons accueillir si vous
le voulez bien maintenant notre invité
qui va passer un long moment avec nous
en fin d'émission par l'or avec lui de
la septième saison des anges à partir de
dimanche rénergie 12 merci d'accueillir
matthieu delormeau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui ont reconnu la musique et les anges
pas reconnu moi du coup ça va me tuer ça
va très bien mais bien voyez vous êtes
ici entre ennemis et
et j'ai eu un rude
on peut être d'accord ou pas d'accord
mais il est ici avec des amis qui vont
débattre avec lui une nouvelle fois vous
êtes là vous l'avez dit ils vont taper
fort mais rassure toi je serai la portée
des joueurs
[Applaudissements]
non je serai là pour les aider a tapé
fort dans cette nouvelle saison
s'annonce comment en deux mois on en
parlera enverra des extraits tout à
l'heure alors en 2000 en plus moi je
mens jamais donc c'est ce qui fait
parfois c'est dangereux pour moi la
promo mais honnêtement on n'a pas été au
top sur toutes les saisons la saison
précédente sept camions marché en
audience la saison 3 pour moi est un peu
loupé franchement celle-là s'annonce
extrêmement bien moi j'ai passé dix
jours là bas avec eux et honnêtement il
ya tout ce qu' on aime
comment vous êtes arrivé comment
écrivez-vous maison non honnêtement ma
gueule donc que vous avez passé du
joueur avec eux je voulais vérifier si
vous aviez toujours
[Applaudissements]
allez on y va
il ya maintenant un jingle qui démarre
car je me dois de les annoncer pour la
personne qui se donne du mal à les faire
voici le vus à l'étranger thé spécial
télé réalité si je vous dis ah oui oui
vous me dites je ne sais pas de quoi il
s'agit et ce à quoi je vous réponds
c'est une émission américaine qui est
diffusée sur mtv vous connaissez mtv
janvier exactement qui connaît le pitch
ces dix garçons et filles les garçons et
des filles qui ont été on a ça va être
dur pour moi mais bon chacun en fait
scientifiquement il y en a un qui se
tiraient avec l'eau c'est comme si on
disait que scientifiquement il ya trois
les trois filles du plateau
correspondent à trois autres d'ailleurs
il ya deux filles pour un garçon oui la
nouvelle édition a commencé c'était
pareil sur les missions des nudistes sur
d8 ya toujours des toujours c'était deux
garçons pour une fille faut toujours
qu'il y en ait deux quoi
mathieu qu'en pensez vous de ça je ne
connais pas du tout mais voilà on va
regarder un extrait pour vous être
agréable et vous nous direz ce que vous
en pensez après regardez vous êtes ici
car vous avez tous un point commun
vous êtes nuls en relation de couple
chacun d'entre vous a suivi des tests de
compatibilité votre conjoint idéal est
ici dix mecs dix filles